all right listen I think we're doing
something good today we talked about
Biden's bribery we we're going to talk
now about Hillary's emails we're going
to talk about Joe Biden's classified
documents I think that while
you and I mostly understand that these
are red herrings and what about ISM from
the right it's not a bad thing when we
have the opportunity to put on the
record everything we know about these
situations so we can refer back to it so
I'm going to give you a couple of
examples here of incredible what about
ISM from right Wingers here is for
example Ron DeSantis interestingly
enough defending Donald Trump against
his recent indictment by immediately
bringing up Hillary Clinton's emails I
know it's satirical and almost a parody
at this point that you ask about a real
37 felony count indictment with pictures
with evidence with Witnesses and they
say well what about Hillary's emails for
which she's been cleared of criminal
wrongdoing but that's what they want to
do here's Ron DeSantis when I was uh uh
in Congress I remember you know Hillary
had the the emails with the classified
and my view was well gee you know as a
naval officer if I would have taken
classified in my apartment I would have
been court-martialed in a New York
minute and yet they seem to not care
care about that and is there a different
standard for a Democrat Secretary of
State versus a former Republican
president I think there needs to be one
standard of Justice in this country
right and that standard of justice is if
there is evidence of criminality
regardless of who you are you get
yourself indicted it's actually sort of
shocking that they're still doing this
and it's not just Ron DeSantis here's
another example here's Republican
Congressman Mike Waltz who again in an
attempt to defend Trump says listen you
can call it what about ISM and then he
brings up Hillary Clinton's email why
not just hand them over if to your point
this happens a lot yeah well look under
if he believed he was privileged on the
the presidential records act then that
is a conversation that I would argue
should have continued to happen because
what's missing also in this conversation
and I can tell you this talk in the
Floridians and and folks back home uh
you can call it what about it what about
ISM or and we will because that's what
it is what have you they're calling it
fairness and there's legal precedent
here when you have the Clinton tapes
when you have the Clinton emails when
you have the fact that the sitting
National Security advisor right now Jake
Sullivan
was sending and laundering classified
documents into an unclassified server on
top of the fact that the sitting
president of the United States admitted
he had documents in his garage that
you're going in and out of people look
at that and say whoa wait a minute
there was prosecutorial discretion there
they didn't prosecute they didn't go
after these folks and all of these other
instances all right you get the point
this actually makes no sense but sense
in the facts don't matter so it in a
sense makes perfect sense that they are
doing something that makes no sense
Donald Trump's indictment is based on 37
felony counts related to mishandling
classified documents obstructing justice
making false statements some of those
actions under the Espionage Act which we
will dig into later as we continue our
Deep dive into this the Hillary Clinton
email controversy was based on
allegations that she used a private
email server for public Communications
this was deemed extremely careless by
the FBI it was not deemed Criminal by
the FBI because it did not appear to
break the law that's what we care about
the Trump indictment says Trump shared a
classified map
related to military operations uh with
people who were not qualified to see
that he knew that it wasn't Declassified
because he said after leaving office
this is classified he improperly stored
boxes containing classified documents by
his toilet in the Ballroom in the shower
he went out of his way to avoid giving
back the documents Hillary Clinton's
email controversy involved emails that
were retroactively classified by the
state department after they were sent or
received an important detail none of
them were marked classified at the time
the Trump indictment alleges Trump got
numerous requests from the justice
department saying just hand the stuff
over hand it over and he didn't do it
the allegations against Trump include
making false statements to the FBI going
to his aides and lawyers and saying Help
Me Lie help me hide help me do
everything to avoid giving these
documents back in the Hillary Clinton
situation Nation she immediately and
voluntarily handed over about thirty
thousand emails to the state department
that were work related and deleted about
thirty thousand personal emails she
deemed irrelevant the right likes to say
well the thirty thousand emails she
deemed irrelevant weren't irrelevant
okay well the investigation hasn't
determined that that's the case the
Trump indictment could result in prison
time for him and Walt nauda who is a
co-conspirator and was also indicted the
Hillary Clinton email controversy was
fully investigated and the determination
was there was not a crime committed and
so charges were not filed the right says
that's because of political bias there
is no evidence of that because the
things Hillary did and what Trump is
accused of are dramatically different so
that's Hillary's emails let's now look
at the Joe Biden part a little bit more
closely
I love my Helix Sleep mattress I've been
sleeping on Helix mattresses for years
now which is why I asked them to be a
sponsor you actually take their famous
sleep quiz takes just a few minutes to
answer questions about your sleep
preferences body type sleep position
whether you have back pain and Helix
will match you with a mattress that's
perfect for you which is really unique
and helpful because a lot of people
don't know where to start when buying a
mattress I certainly didn't their newest
collection of mattresses called Helix
Elite come with a built-in glacial text
layer to keep you cool at night an extra
layer of foam for pressure relief and
thousands of extra micro coils for Best
in Class support and durability all of
their mattresses ship right to your door
totally free they come with a 10 or 15
year warranty and you get 100 nights to
decide if you like it my audience also
gets a whopping 20 percent off all order
plus two free pillows go to
helixsleep.com Pacman the link is in the
description